president-elect had his first press
conference after the elections and he
for the first time admitted that other
Russians had been behind the recent
election hacks what do you think his
response might be well I was I was very
pleased to hear him acknowledge that the
Russians were primarily behind the
serious attacks on the election he did
point out correctly there are other
nations who have enjoyed who have
engaged in the same kind of activities
but I'm glad that he admitted or stated
that the Russians had been responsible
for the attacks that are concerning the
election because there's no doubt about
it
yes but at the same time here he says
that the fact that Putin likes him is an
asset and not a liability and under
Trump's leadership in the United States
Putin will treat this country much
better and won't opted for another time
for hacks what do you think of this well
I believe that Vladimir Putin is a
murderer
and a thug and he's a product of the KGB
and he will take whatever advantage that
he can I have now seen three presidents
President Bush President Clinton and
President Obama who all believed that
they could have a new relationship with
Vladimir Putin they praised him George W
Bush said I looked into his eyes and saw
his soul and of course with the with the
Obama campaign the reset button under
the Obama presidency and what we have to
understand is what Vladimir Putin is and
so we have to go back to the days of
Ronald Reagan peace through strength the
only thing that Vladimir Putin
understands is strength that for
aggression the price is higher
than what he might gain from it and we
have watched him dismantle the Ukraine
take Crimea now use his airplanes to
drop precision weapons on hospitals in
Aleppo military buildup in Kaliningrad
the list goes on and on and he's doing
that with a country that's very weak
economically and so we need to have a
return to peace through strength yes
we'll be glad to talk to Vladimir Putin
but only from a position of strength
that's mister fromm back understand this
I don't know what's your overall
impression of the tramps press
conference because there was a conflict
between mr. Trump and CNN he accused
them and having said that these are fake
news and things like that what's your
overall impression besides from this
particular remark about Russia and
election hacks I could go for a long
time but I'll be as brief as possible
president-elect Trump has changed the
way politics are conducted in the United
States with the use of Twitter with a
lack this was the first press conference
in I think five months that he is held
that's unheard of and he is able to
energize his base of support at the same
time his approval ratings are lower than
any president in modern times as he
assumes the office of the presidency so
we are seeing a very unusual time in
American politics and a very polarized
America and I would like to see him
reach out to all Americans whether they
supported him or whether they opposed
him and he's successful so for me to
criticize what he's done
obviously he succeeded and in politics
the ultimate result is what counts